Welcome back everyone. This is the way.
This will  be my full Mandalorian season
4 teaser video there were a whole bunch
of story lines and plot threads they set
up at the end of season three so I'll
explain what's going on with the show as
well as all the larger shows in the
mandovers getting ready to cross over in
the thrawn movie and when everything is
coming out if you're brand new to the
channel we're getting ready for the
Ahsoka episodes that's going to be the
next part of the timeline those will
happen later this year of course I'll be
doing episode videos for them be sure to
subscribe to get them all I'll do a
special giveaway when those start too
we'll get another Ahsoka trailer pretty
soon that'll explain a little bit more
of the story I just did a bunch of
Ahsoka videos explaining who all the new
characters are like those new dark Jedi
that aren't technically Sith careful for
spoilers from the season 3 finale if you
haven't seen it yet but just starting
with number 10 the Mandalorian in grogu
left the armors group the larger group
of mandalorians led by Boca tan the
night owls the ones that hit so far come
back to Mandalore there are other
mandalorians out there that will slowly
crawl out of the woodwork and come back
but they did it this way to soft reboot
the show heading into season 4 so that
the show could get back to being mostly
about the two of them having adventures
together like season one season three
got a little out of control trying to
handle the larger storytelling during
this part of the timeline leading up to
the Grand Admiral thrawn movie plot
dealing with all the stuff that they set
up during season one and season two with
the mandalorians retaking the planet
Mandalore from MAF Gideon the Empire
setting up everything that was happening
in the Ahsoka series as well as Skeleton
Crew they haven't been hijacked quite as
much by Skeleton Crew they've kind of
been developing that as its own thing
even though it's part of the mandovers
grand Admiral thrawn's return will
Herald in the re-emergence of our
military about thrawn's return
heir to the Empire but one of the big
things about the Mandalorian during
season one is that it was meant to be
this small little part of the Galaxy a
smaller show about this character in
grogu just going around having
adventures and it kind of Spun up into a
much bigger thing during season two and
season three so the kind of soft
resetting the show now that we have
Ahsoka and we have these other shows
that can handle some of that larger
storytelling they don't have to all do
it during the Mandalorian number nine
the praetorian guard destroyed grogu's
ig-12 Mech body they reused the memory
core from the head of the other ig-11
Droid at Carson tiva's New Republic
Adelphi phase to fix the old ig11 like
their friend ig-11 wrapping up that
season-long plot that started in episode
one allowing ig-11 to become gurukarga's
new martial so he'll continue to do that
during season three like those
characters will come back during season
three briefly but grogu will not use the
mech body anymore he'll just go back to
using his pod in walking around like
they're getting better with a special
effects even though it looks so
hilarious when Roku is walking around on
his own like his tiny little legs trying
to carry him around with mando
yeah
groco will also continue to get more
beskar armor pieces Armando will give
him more armor pieces through the armor
he has the chainmail shirt that he wore
all season long if you didn't see it he
was wearing that underneath his little
potato sack the entire season the armor
also gave him his rondelle upgrade
that's a little chest plate here he'll
get at least one more armor piece from
the armor like bogotan the armor of
those characters will still be featured
during season four but they just won't
be as big as they were during season
three they only go visit them briefly
number eight since Mando adopted grogu
asked his son he took the Creed he
became a Mandalorian as part of the
Armor's Clan formerly the children of
the watch he achieved the next level in
their group apprenticeship the armor
charged him with taking din grogu now as
his name is on his journeys which is
what they'll be doing between season
three and season 4 and during season
four like a series of Adventures bounty
hunting in the outer rim is Mando told
Carson tiva they wanted to let you know
what they're going to be doing between
Adventures too which is why greed karga
gave him the Little House On The Range
like little Home on the Range because
we're talking about space Western here
it was very Western Vibes at the end of
the episode but the whole idea with all
these bounty hunting missions is that
grogu will slowly learn more about the
actual stock and trade of bounty hunting
in the way that Mando mostly did that
during season one I can bring you in
warm
or I can bring you in cold having them
going around the Galaxy bounty hunting
is an easy way to also Cameo them on
other series like the Ahsoka series even
the Skeleton Crew series eventually even
though technically that's going to take
place in a completely different part of
the Galaxy so structurally it just makes
it easier for them to cameo grogu in
Mando on other shows now and that
they've separated them from the
Mandalore storyline the other
mandalorians number seven big surprise
too is that din djarin's first name is
technically Djarin I always thought that
his first name was din apparently not
the Mandalorian culture I guess just
uses the first name surname convention a
little bit differently but Mando pretty
much everybody else on the show with a
few exceptions will just call him grogu
going forward I think only the armor the
other members of the armorers group will
probably use his full din grogu name
just because she's so formal all the
time number six grogu will continue to
train in the force the same way that
Ahsoka continued to deepen her
Connection in the force practice the
force outside of the Jedi Order after
she had left his path in the force will
be kind of like Ahsoka she's a good
template for him like he isn't pursuing
the Jedi path under Luke Skywalker in
his Jedi Academy he's not becoming a
gray Jedi or anything like that even
Dave filoni says that Ahsoka isn't a
gray Jedi Technically she's not like the
bendu either because he practiced both
the dark side and the light side Force
equally becoming true neutral Jed I am
Sith really Ashley
the light and the dark
I'm the one in the middle the Bandu in
grogu in Ahsoka will just continue to be
more light side-leaning Force users they
use the Jedi term during the Ahsoka
trailer but Dave filonia said in the
past too and even Ahsoka herself in her
own episodes previously has told people
that she is no Jedi I think the reason
they did it this way in the Ahsoka
trailer is just for people who aren't
hardcore Star Wars fans don't really
understand the technicalities of the way
that Ahsoka thinks of herself that way
it was more for their benefit to let
them know that there would be forced
users in the series so they just want to
make it as simple as possible like oh
you have Jedi then you have something
else here that seemed kind of like evil
Jedi which should technically be called
Dark Jedi and when Disney is marketing
grogu Star Wars merch for grogu they'll
just continue to think of him the same
way like they'll call him Jedi even
though technically he is not a Jedi but
as grogu continues to encounter more
Force users like more people from the
Canon start showing up on the series and
a lot of people expecting him to meet
Ezra Bridger or the other characters
they'll continue continue to pass on
more lessons to grogu in the force but
Ahsoka already said that she wasn't
going to become grogu's bastard or she
couldn't be grogu's Master just because
she's so traumatized from what happened
to Anakin Skywalker and she sends the
same fear in grogu so on a small chance
that the same fate could befall grogu
she didn't want to take that chance but
she will continue to help him with his
path through the force like she'll Point
him in directions that she thinks will
help him deepen his connection to the
force number five the Mandalorian season
4 will likely release in early 2025 at
the rate they've been producing episodes
recently of all these new series before
this year happened I would have said
late 2024 because they're going to start
filming by October this year but Disney
just pumped the brakes slowed down all
the Star Wars all the Marvel series
releases even the movie releases so
right now the 2024 Star Wars series they
confirmed being released are Skeleton
Crew first which is a Mandalorian
spin-off during the same part of the
timeline in a completely different part
of the Galaxy that'll probably cover
some of the other members of The Shadow
Council on the Empire side of things too
like they'll still continue to be a big
thing in this part of the timeline on
all the different shows Star Wars
acolyte which is a hybrid public era
shows that a hundred years before
Phantom Menace about the rise of the
Sith like a completely separate thing
maybe there'll be some loose references
to what's happening in this part of the
timeline but not that many because it'll
just be covering stuff way earlier on
the timeline the bad batch season 3
entails of the Jedi season 2. number
four because the Mandalorian season 4
will release after Ahsoka season one in
Ezra Bridger Sabine Wren the crew of the
ghosts like Hera are coming back during
that we even saw Zeb Cameo during the
Mandalorian season 3 since they're all
coming back during that grogu will meet
Ezra Bridger eventually and he'll learn
more force abilities from him that is to
say Ezra will pass on some of his wisdom
to grogu I believe part of the idea with
Ezra Bridger being lost in the unknown
regions for all these years and then
eventually finding him he will come back
a changed person like fundamentally
he'll be the same person but but he'll
have gone through so much stuff that
he'll learn so many new things I'm not
expecting a giant Cameo scene from Mando
and grogu during the Ahsoka series maybe
just like a small one in mostly the
antagonist of that will be great Admiral
thrawn but during the Ahsoka series they
will address what's happening with some
of these other Shadow council members
they'll still be around during the
Mandalorian season four though like
they'll slowly start dealing with all
the different ones it was just a teaser
during season three number three season
four will also be released before the
big thrawn movie the heir to the Empire
movie based on the original thrawn
trilogy Dave filoni said they're
continuing to mine the expanded universe
thrawn Trilogy that part of the Legends
Canon for the story The Great books I
would recommend checking them out at
some point but obviously they're
changing some of that story to fit with
the canon in present day but the thrawn
movie is meant to serve as the
culmination of all the storylines that
have been happening since Mandalorian
season 1 on the Ahsoka series that'll be
happening during the new Skeleton Crew
series even though we only just got the
teaser for that but the way that John
Favreau talks about it they'll just stay
in this part of the timeline continuing
to tell stories for a long time he
didn't say how many seasons all the
different shows are going to get or if
there be more spin-off shows he just
said they had 20 plus years that they
could tell stories and during this part
of the timeline in that this wouldn't be
the end of them doing mandover stuff so
the Dave filoni movie winds up doing as
well as we all expected to they will
probably do more of that kind of stuff
part of the reason why lucasfilm
announced so many different movies in
different parts of the timeline is
because it's a shotgun method like
they're not committing to full trilogies
from any of the different parts of the
timeline yet they'd want to see how
these first movies do but number two
because of this season 4 could
theoretically be the last season of the
Mandalorian just depending on what's
going on behind the scenes with all the
mandover shows at the time but that
doesn't mean they'll stop telling grogu
stories during this part of the timeline
they've already confirmed that there are
plans for Ahsoka season 2 but they won't
formally announce that till after season
one airs but number one because they
just announced the new sequel movies set
15 years after the rise of Skywalker
grogu would be about the same age Yoda
was when he became a Jedi master meaning
by then he'd be fully matured he'd have
long since started speaking the basic
tongue like everyone else so grogu could
actually be in that sequel era movie but
the thing is John Favreau said a lot of
weird stuff about grogu being in the
future movies but after all the
announcements like after we learn the
truth of what's actually going on
they're being just kind of selective
about where grogu does appear so the
thrawn movie I think is meant to be the
first movie that grogu actually appears
in and it sounds like the sequel movie
will be the first one to come out in
2025 and if you think about it they
don't want to spoil what happens to
grogu by showing you older the Chad
version of grogu before they show you
the young version of groco in the movies
so I'm only expecting some Easter eggs
some light references to what's
happening with grogu in that part of the
timeline like the new Jedi Order that
just gets into the whole idea of him
becoming the Mandalorian Jedi like he is
the next coming of tar Vizsla basically
all hoping that he forges a new light
saber and that's like the new version
the darksaber even though I don't think
he's gonna wield the darksaber early
Theory right now is that eventually
bogatan Will Repair that with the help
of the Jedi Droid which is actually with
Ahsoka right now on her ship as we saw
in the footage and if grogu builds his
own lightsaber it'll be something
completely different so you can let me
know in the comments what kind of
lightsaber do you want him to wield in
the future I'll start doing more Ahsoka
videos really soon too so if you have
any requests just leave them in the
comments below everyone click here for
my full Mandalorian season 3 episode 8
finale video and click here for all my
Ahsoka trailer videos to find out what's
going on with grand Admiral thrawn thank
you so much for watching everyone stay
safe this is the way!